[Music]
when it comes to development most tools
that you come across have a limited
shelf life but despite this constant
churn there's one thing that remains
consistent and that's good it's easy to
take it for granted but when you take a
step back you'll find that git has
completely revolutionized the software
world it's essentially a history book of
your code and services like github make
open source software accessible to the
world in today's video I'll show you the
basics of get along with some advanced
pro tips and I'll even invite you to
collaborate with me on a pull request on
github in exchange for a free sticker I
think that's a pretty good deal so if
you're new here like and subscribe and
I'll give you further instructions
throughout this video so what is get
exactly it's a version control system
but really what that boils down to is a
system for managing your files building
software is a series of small milestones
where each milestone is just writing
code and a bunch of different files your
app will constantly move from a state of
chaos to stability and gate gives you a
way to keep track of all of these
changes and it does so in a way that
allows you to create multiple branches
or paths that you can go down and then
merge them in later facilitating
collaboration between large groups of
developers so today I'm going to show
you how this all works by building a
piece of open source node software that
we can all collaborate on the software
itself is a command-line utility that
will allow you to encrypt your mailing
address and then add it to the github
repo so I can mail you a sticker in my
current working directory I just have an
index J s file and a package.json I'll
go ahead and click on the source control
icon and you'll notice it says no source
control provider is registered the first
thing we'll need to do is initialize get
to start tracking our files and there
are two ways we can do this we can
either do it directly in vs code or we
can do it from the command line you
should definitely try to memorize all
the commands I show you in this video
but it's often faster to run them with
vs codes integrated tooling and I'll
show you both methods throughout this
video so first we'll go ahead and run
get an it from the command line and
you'll see that initializes an empty git
repository in our current working
directory you'll notice it adds our two
files to the changes list in the source
control panel so this tells us which
files have changed since the previous
snapshot of the source code because
we're in a brand-new project both these
files have a u icon
which means untracked or that their
newly created on this working directory
now a quick pro tip when you initialize
it get repo it creates a hidden get
directory if you want to completely
uninitialized it or remove it from your
project you can just remove that
directory but be careful with that one
now a second pro tip is to install the
get lense plugin for vs code it embeds
all kinds of useful information directly
in your code and gives you this extra
panel where you can easily navigate your
git history the next important thing
when setting up a github repo is to
create a git ignore file you don't want
everything in source control for example
you definitely want to keep out any
sensitive private API keys and you'll
also want to filter out the source code
for your dependencies like your node
modules and any unnecessary log files
git will automatically look at this get
ignore file and filter out anything that
matches the file path or pattern you can
create this file manually but the pro
way to do it is to use AVS code plug-in
to automatically generate all the
defaults for your environment so that
saves us a bunch of time and now we can
move on to the next concept of how do I
take a snapshot or a commit of my
current working directory a commit is
like a page in a history book that has
its own unique ID and can't ever be
changed without get knowing about it the
first thing we want to do is stage the
files that we want included in this
commit use stage files by running git
add and you can add individual files or
the entire working directory by just
using a period and BS code makes it
really easy to stage or unstaged files
by just clicking the plus or minus
button and you can unstaged files from
the command line by running git reset
but be careful with this one because
there's a hard flag and if you use it it
will not only unstaged the files but
delete them forever so if we run that
one right now on our new project it will
delete everything and we'll have to
start over from scratch and with that
I'll give you one of my most important
pro tips which is to make many small
commits this practice will not only help
prevent catastrophic losses of code but
it will also just make your code changes
a lot easier to follow now we're ready
for our first command the first thing we
want to do is run git add to stage our
files then we run git commit with the EM
flag to add a descriptive message about
what we changed in our code a pro tip
here is to use an emoji to get more
github stars on your project because
github stars are the best way to tell
how good a software project really is
and you can also make your comments
multi-line to provide a summary on the
first line and then a more descriptive
set of changes on the second line you'll
notice that that takes the files out of
the stage changes and gives us a clean
working directory and it will tell us
exactly which files were created
modified or deleted as part of this
commit now if we go into our git lens
plug-in you can see we have a history of
code changes that we can navigate
through and see exactly which lines of
code changed up until this point we've
been working on what's called the master
branch which is like the main trunk on
the tree that contains the actual source
code that you're releasing and
delivering to your customers so what
happens when you have a stable code base
and you need to fix a bug or you want to
experiment with a new feature what
you'll typically do in git is create a
new branch based on your most recent
commit and go and fix the bug on the
separate branch and then merge it back
into the master branch once it's ready
this means we can have multiple
developers working on the same code base
on their own branches without stepping
on each other's toes you can see all the
current branches in your codebase by
running git branch which for us would
just be the master you can switch
between branches and get by running the
check out command in our case the branch
hasn't been created yet so we'll go
ahead and create it by using the be flag
and we'll give it a name of feature so
now any code that we write in here will
be isolated to this branch now we can
fast forward into the future and you'll
see I've written a bunch of code in this
branch so currently this code is just
sitting in the working directory so I
need to commit it to this feature branch
this time I'll run my commit directly in
vs code and then we can switch back to
the master branch and you'll see that
all of our new files disappear and we're
back to the original state on the master
at this point I'd like to point out that
you don't necessarily have to commit
your files before switching to the
master branch there's a another
mechanism to save your work in progress
if you're working on something that's
half-finished
or experimental you can use a command
called git stash this will save all of
your current changes without committing
them and then revert back to a clean
working directory then later at some
point in the future when you want to get
back to work you can either pop or apply
the changes in that stash to your
current working directory so kind of
just like it sounds you're stashing away
your current changes to be used at some
later point
so stashing is just a handy thing to
know and an alternative to committing
your code if you're not quite ready to
do so
in our case we're all done building our
feature so what we want to do now is
merge that feature into the master
branch so now we'll go ahead and check
out the master branch and then if we run
get merged with the name of our feature
branch it will merge the latest commits
from the feature into the master and
you'll notice the commit ID is the same
for both the feature and master branch
so that was a pretty simple use case but
merging is the place you're most likely
to run into problems because you might
be working on a feature branch and then
the master branch has changes that
eventually lead to merge conflicts on
the Left we have a line of code that we
implemented in our feature branch and
then on the right we have a new change
that happened in the master branch while
we are working that affected the same
line of code so merging these files is
not possible out-of-the-box because git
doesn't know which change to use the S
code will give you some options to
resolve these conflicts for example you
might accept the current change accept
the incoming change or Bowl when you run
into a conflict you'll want to first
review it and then a lot of times it's
best to just abort the merge all
together and fix the files manually I
already mentioned that it's a good
practice to implement a lot of small
commits because it's easier to fix a
conflict on one file as opposed to a
hundred files then in the previous
example we merged a feature branch into
the master branch but a lot of times
when you're working on a feature you'll
want to merge the master branch back
into your feature to get the latest code
because if something on the master
branch changes it means someone could
have been writing code in the same place
that you're writing code or there might
be some breaking changes that changed
the way your feature is going to work so
if you're working on a feature for an
extended period of time you'll want to
merge in the master branch any time it
changes or maybe once a day if it's a
really active repo now there's one last
pro tip that I want to give you that's
related to merging a lot of times on a
feature branch you'll create a lot of
different commits and these commits are
kind of irrelevant to what's going on in
the master branch you can see here that
our feature branch is three commits
ahead of our master branch and it has a
bunch of comments about adding useless
emojis to the code instead of merging
all of these commits into the master
branch you can use the squash flag to
squash them down into a single commit
when you do your merge this will keep
the change history nice and concise on
the master branch but still preserve all
of the original commits on the feature
branch itself when you merge with the
squash flag
it won't actually change the head commit
on the master branch so you'll need to
add an additional commit on your own
that says something like merged in
feature branch and that gives us a nice
compact change history on the master so
now that we know how to do all this get
stuff locally let's see how we can do it
remotely with github pushing a repo to
github is actually really easy first we
just need to create a repository on
github and then it will give us the
commands to run to push our code to this
location the first command is get remote
which connects your local code to this
remote repository and the second command
is get push which will actually push the
files to the remote repository so if we
run the commands and then refresh the
page we should see our code is now on
github that was super easy but the next
thing I want to show you is how to take
someone's existing code fork it create
some changes and then create a pull
request to merge your code into another
person's project and that's exactly what
you'll need to do to get the free
sticker so this is the typical pattern
that you'll see when contributing to any
open-source project
step one is to fork the existing project
forking will copy the code from the
source and make it a repo under your own
github account after you fork it you'll
then want to clone your fork to your
local machine so you can start making
changes to it the git clone command just
allows you to copy the code from a
remote repository to your local computer
once you have that cloned you can open
it up in vs code and in this case serial
first want to run npm install to install
the dependencies then you can run git
checkout flag be with my sticker as the
branch name which again will create and
move you into this new branch and then
i've added a special command to this
repo called npm run address and that's
going to prompt you for the information
that i need for your mailing address
when you're done with that it will print
out an encrypted base64 string from
there you'll go into the stickers
directory and create a new file that's
your github username dot txt
then you'll copy and paste this encoded
string into that file so just a side
note on security your address is going
into a public repo but it's encrypted
with the RSA algorithm this means that
you are able to encrypt data with the
public key but I'm the only one with the
private key that can decrypt it I have
the private key on a thumb drive which
I'll destroy after this giveaway and
hacking the private key by brute force
is essentially impossible
unless someone physically steals the
private key your address should be safe
in this public format but I do feel
obligated to give you that disclaimer
first now go ahead and save the text
file then run get ad and get commit with
whatever message you want to put in
there now we have all of the necessary
changes committed on our local machine
we'll need to push this branch to our
remote fork for that we can just say git
push origin with the branch name and
that will push the branch to github then
on github you'll see the option to
create a new pull request a pull request
is just like a merge but it has the
additional step of needing to pulling
the remote changes in other words a pull
request is like saying pulling my remote
changes and then merge them into the
master branch so that's how you
contribute to an open-source project I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
hopefully that leaves you with some of
the basic tools needed to contribute to
open source software there's a whole lot
more that can be covered on this topic
so let me know what you want to see next
in the comments and if you want to get
really good at this kind of stuff
consider becoming a pro member at
angular firebase com thanks for watching
and I'll talk to you soon